the Joe Rogan experience and you get to
tour like I got to go on tour I got to
go to Malaysia to do comedy what was
that like [ __ ] lit like they were I
to me I did this whole Asia tour and I
was like Malaysia is of all the
countries I did because I did Hong Kong
and I did Japan and there was one more
and I'm blanking on it Oh Singapore and
of all of them I had not been to
Malaysia I'd been to the others and I
had less context for Malaysia I knew
some of my clothing was made there and I
knew that we ship a lot of our recycling
there or try to but I had no contacts
and it's interesting because you're
there and everyone is in a hijab and
they're Asian so that's like you don't
see that a time yeah cuz they're all
Muslim Muslim Imams and it look like
Asian like Japanese or Chinese
yeah like Asian wow and they were just
the crowd was on fire real I thought
there's gonna be super conservative wear
it I made fun of the Chinese a little
bit they were like yes and they just
went nuts and they were awesome and I
just remember thinking like and some
people are expats but a lot of them were
just full-on Malaysian and it's all
because of Netflix and I was like that's
it's so special to have your comment I'm
gonna go tour in Russia like places that
you have no real context for are feeling
your heart and they're understanding
what you're saying and it's resonating
with people that are nothing like you
you're gonna tour in Russia yeah I'm
going to Europe like it's just cool and
then they know other comics like they
know who you are they know who other
people and it's just it's this seek it's
this like language at this community
that we're you and I are members of and
people all want to be part of it
right because people want to feel seen
and heard and that comedy validates that
weird voice in your head and it lets you
know that you're not alone and for so
many people that feel alone it's so
powerful to feel like you're being seen
and that somebody understands you mm-hmm
and that's why it's so important have so
many different kinds of comedy different
shapes and colors just so people can
choose who they resonate with right I'm
never gonna be able to reach everyone
and that's okay
yeah of course touring in Russia is
gonna be a trip she let's just did that
I'm gonna ask Bert Kreischer for tips
did Bert work over there well no but
show machines
yeah yeah I had to get drunk on a train
yeah my right tell you how to get drunk
anywhere I got a letter today I'm going
to Vietnam and it was in bold and I've
been to Vietnam before like for funsies
but it was in bold and it was like this
like written out like imprisonment will
be issued there will be no jokes about
do not mention Vietnam War Vietnam like
all these things and I legit was like I
do mention the Vietnam War so just
please remind me day before not to have
that one joke it's not a joke about the
Vietnam War I just it's in there as part
of the set up but some countries like
you do military shows they have like a
no burden list like you can't there's
certain things you can't say you know
you do a military show yeah you can't
make like drug jokes please not make fun
of the president which I get and some
countries are like no [ __ ] joke do
not say it like so yeah they wouldn't
let you joke about Vietnam hey sorry
sorry about all that I feel like I could
but then like try explaining contacts to
someone that just wants you in jail yeah
I was going to China I did Hong Kong and
I had Beijing and they cancelled it to
honor so random the Tiananmen Square
massacre which of course should have
been honored prior but it wasn't and
they cancelled all comedy not that there
was a ton across the land and so but
they canceled they canceled it and it's
that it's just the thing where we're
very lucky in this country you can say
whatever you want you're right send it
your neighbors knows but we that freedom
is totally not to be taken for granted
[Applause]